last night i went out with an nbc crew
we went out around town and we talked to
a lot of fans last night i went to a
tattoo parlor last night and talked to a
guy who's done more than 20 patrick
mahomes tattoos on people one of which a
full face
was an eight-hour job on a woman
and so
i just
you're sensing this thing around this
town like no matter what team they've
had in the past
you have to go all the way back to lenny
dawson and hank stram for a city
uh in in a civic way to be as excited as
this city is and so i mentioned that
because i think their home field edge
here is going to be gigantic
i've never been in a tattoo parlor
just merely being there does does it
create a temptation to get a tattoo
peter
last chance
are you sure you don't want to get a
tattoo
i desperately want a tattoo
yes i have to tell you we're there about
10 o'clock last night and i said to
marissa boyajian the producer i said if
you get one i'll get one
and
okay so i was lying
okay i was lying i i don't i had i was
not gonna get one i have no idea i have
no desire to put ink on my skin but
you know i know everybody else does it
now me and you are the last two holdouts
on planet earth by the way
well would you guess what i i owe you
would you get an o.u bobcats i mean what
would it be if you would get one no i
would not get an ou bobcat i i don't
i think i would get ann
you know my wife's name i'd get it i'd
get it right across here you know i i
think i think it would be lovely i'd get
the mike tyson effect
oh boy i think we may have some folks in
graphics who can give you at least a
glimpse of what that would look like i
have a feeling we'll be seeing that at
some point over the next couple of hours
peter's in missouri on assignment with
the chiefs he was at a tattoo parlor
last night we talked earlier in the
program about whether or not being in
the tattoo parlor tempted him to get a
tattoo he said it did and he eventually
said that the tattoo he would get would
be his wife's name anne on his forehead
and there it is if you're watching on
nbcs under sky sports usa there it is
peter although the alternative if you're
going to go face tattoo we've also got
the mike tyson i like the mike tyson
better there's there's probably a way to
work both in you could do the mike tyson
tattoo with ann in there
somewhere i'll tell you i kind of love
the mike tyson because i'm such a
pugilit i'm such a pugilist mike you
know i i'm a i'm a fighter and not a
lover as you well know
and uh i think both tattoos would look
good i think there's room for both
because i have a rather
uh expansive forehead
and my face is also large i have a very
large melon
and uh so i i mean maybe maybe i should
rethink that today could you imagine ann
king if i went home with anne tattooed
on my forehead would she throw me out of
the house or love me forever i'm not
really sure
yeah i don't know that that's one of
those if it's a face tattoo generally
and it isn't her name then you got a
problem but if it's her name then it
creates a real dilemma as to the future
of the relationship um it's just good
that you weren't in a tattoo parlor
after having a few of your favorite
beverages because who knows where it
goes from there and my my guess is that
65 of all tattoos are done when the
person getting the tattoo is under the
influence of some sort of external
substance
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports